Pierce Morgan is editor-at-large at
Daily Mail comm and he joins us tonight
Pierce thanks a lot for coming on
so without mocking this I mean let's
just take it seriously for a second the
idea that people currently behind bars
who have not completed their sentences
but are serving them should be allowed
to choose our leaders is this a good
idea you know Chuck I was watching the
CNN Town Hall when Bernie Sanders said
what he said about the Boston Marathon
bomber and I literally spat my drink out
and it was a nice glass of red wine so
it was a senseless waste of good alcohol
but I spat it out because I couldn't
really believe what I was hearing this
is a guy frontrunner he said to be the
potential nominee of the Democratic
Party to beat Donald Trump that's their
plan that's what they want to do and
their main selling point right now in a
CNN Town Hall is that they want the
Boston Marathon bomber to get a vote
while he's in prison while he's on death
row and whilst you saved on mocha how
can we not mock it this is the stuff of
utter lunacy and it's the kind of stuff
that I think I'll be watching the show
for a long time this kind of invasion of
woke thought which is now really sending
people nuts I think is now being
extended to areas like the penal system
and they're looking at this and saying
yeah that makes perfect sense
it makes perfect sense that rapists
pedophiles terrorists people guilty of
treason mass murderers serial killers
they should all have the right to vote
that is the most important thing here's
what I would ask them and there's an
irony in me putting this question Tucker
which you will immediately understand
but if you ask the very same Democratic
candidates who support this who want the
right to vote to exist for felons I know
it's asking how they would feel about
the right to own or buy and I would love
it as somebody who has a view that is
completely different to you about gonca
Brown was rabid if felons were all you
know treated as they are I'm not allowed
to have guns they're not it's very
difficult for any felon in America to
come out if they have more than a one
year sentence and own or buy a gun
that's I'm relieved about that right but
that is you know according to the
Democrats and their position on this
speaking that is an infringement on
their constitutional rights so why
aren't they campaigning at the same time
for felons to have the constitutional
right that's surrounded by a gun so what
they're saying is we don't trust you to
go deer hunting but we want you to
choose our leaders our next president so
what they're really saying is we don't
care at all about anything we're not
Saul we want is power and if we see a
reservoir of potential voters we're
gonna we're gonna tap that right and you
and you touched on I think another issue
here a very serious one which is look at
the voting intentions of some of what
these felons will because even be be
having so say you're a convicted mass
rapist you've raped 20 women well how
are you going to cast your vote if
you're allowed to vote it's not gonna be
for anyone who is promoting the safety
of women is it so there is a direct
consequence and direct electoral voting
consequence in allowing serious
offenders to vote I you know I would
extend it to I wouldn't allow any felons
to vote at all while they're in prison
they're not allowed to walk out free in
South Street so just don't let anybody
have a vote while there is that's what
punishments supposed to be about you
lose your rights to a normal life but I
would also extend it to certainly for
anything over the most tiny miniscule
offenses I would say look you can come
out and we're gonna watch you for five
years and we're gonna see if you're
genuinely rehabilitated if you don't
reimburse five years as sadly many
felons do if you don't really look at
you and if we perceive you not to be a
threat to society not to be a potential
rear fender then we may consider
restoring your right to vote in this
country but I certainly wouldn't ever
extend it to anyone guilty of any major
serious offense whether they're in
prison or whether they get let out later
on because to me at some point there has
to be genuine punishment for serious
offenses but you know a marathon is
young a whole point thing we don't want
to vote we want a country that's
well-run I mean that really is that the
enfranchisement if everyone is a goal
but the the real goal the overarching
goal is a peaceful Placid non-corrupt
prosperous well-run country right so why
was the river right why is an irony that
the same Democrats are screaming every
single second of every day about Trump
and collusion he's a criminal
you have sucked in justice we can't have
a criminal running the country and yet
at the same time they campaigning for
every criminal in the country to have
the right to vote for a president I mean
again this is full of ludicrous irony so
when you say to me piers I don't want
you to mock this I'm finding that
instruction very difficult mr. Karlson
but so sure I mean you'd have to think
if you're the Democrats and all you care
about is taking power seizing it back
from the Trump administration that you
would have [ __ ] this through there's
some very smart people on the Democratic
side some pretty ruthless players
nothing they've been talking about for
the past two months has broad or even
majority appeal in this country they're
losing the election already why are they
doing this what is happening here I
think they're on a political suicide
mission and I've said this for quite
some time I felt with the Mulla
collusion obsession which many of the
mainstream media if had which many
Democrats have had which all the usual
suspect Democrat the supporting liberal
celebrities have had that this collusion
obsession if it turned out as it has
that mullah found there was no collusion
then that would actually act as one of
the greats
voting bonuses for Donald Trump
imaginable
it was two years of the establishment
writing the media and celebrities trying
to depose him as president on a
basically fake news story that he
colluded with the Russians and so here
we are we're now 18 months from an
election and the Democrats rather than
just take their punishment on the Mullen
report and say you know what there was
in collusion Muller our knight in
shining armor has concluded that so we
need to move on and try and get behind a
candidate who has a positive brilliant
idea and vision for the country
which they can offer up against Trump
who they see as their nemesis instead
you have all these candidates last night
led by Bernie Sanders Kamala Harris
who's a lawyer for goodness sake all
basically now standing there saying
here's a great idea to win over middle
America that the Heartland that Donald
Trump got got away from us in that last
election we're gonna really campaign
that the Boston Marathon bomber should
allowed to vote what part of that does
not scream to the Democratic leadership
this is madness this is a way to get
Trump reelected maybe they're all
sleeper cells Tucker
tsarnaev should be voting free
presumably for them Piers Morgan thank
you for that incisive and now give me
the vote next Chuck yeah but where does
this end yeah I'd be happy here's work
great to see you thank you